welcome back to new rock stars and what
if just showed us that some of our worst
villains in the mcu could actually be
pretty chill if someone would just take
the time to explain to them why their
plans are evil but of course the flip
side of that means that some of our
heroes are just one little baby step
away from being total monsters like
peter quill is this guy cursed with a
celestial bloodline that had he not met
the right friends along his way would
have made him just as evil or worse than
thanos that's what we're talking about
today in rogue
theory
it's a show where we pitch the wildest
theories to the nerdy titles we love i
am eric um vos and going rogue with me
today is mastertainment mt how you doing
mt dude i'm doing good i'm feeling good
i had just saw chadwick and my heart is
just filled with love i feel good too
also here with us is our very own half
human half celestial tommy bechtol hello
everyone
hello
what you don't have a minute to spend on
your dear old dad
i don't remember him winking you added
the wink
his eyes glow
i'd be so concerned if i was peter be
like who are you
don't wink at me sir
then we have the perfect lady to lead a
heist with this crew of misfits jess
hi hello hello did you forget your last
name eric huh at the beginning you said
eric
oh no
brain is fried all right he's been
thinking of theories all day leave him
alone he's just scrolling i'm sorry he's
a
he strong the test well let's talk about
this what if episode 2 what if t'challa
became a star lord explores the classic
nature vs nurture debate suggesting that
t'challa could positively impact the
morality of characters like thanos and
yondu nebula and more completely
changing their trajectory just by being
friends with them but on the flip side
the final scene suggests that peter
quill had he not met the ravagers or the
guardians would have met his biological
father ego first and might have been
more corruptible via his genealogical
link do we think peter quill could be
cursed with the blood of a power-hungry
celestial and now in the live-action mcu
with gamora not really in his life at
the moment is he destined to turn
evil
evil
[Music]
is his one and only name i don't think
he's i don't think he would turn evil
sorry to jump in i don't think he would
turn evil because it's still peter quill
and i think still so in the timeline
that we have right now right his mother
still passed away so he still has that
like that beacon of light in his life
has gone away and it was by his dad's
hands in the film so it's just like i
think he'd still have that
that he would be on board and he still
wouldn't understand like corruption and
evil when he sees it and when his dad's
trying to blow up the world and take
over all the galaxies i think he could
still be like i don't want to do this
this doesn't seem right mom wouldn't
like this and he'd still inevitably
figure out that his dad was the reason
why his mom is dead so i don't think
he's gonna be evil but following like
the new live action what's going on
between him and gamora i i don't think
i'd still make him turn evil if that i
don't know i don't know the the seeds
are all there
peter quill is a liar
peter quill is a petulant child he gets
very jealous and he's competitive okay
he's willing to
uh you know do duplicitous things to get
what he wants like he's not exactly you
know a you know lawful good character to
begin with so i i don't know i feel like
he is very corruptable and we've seen
seats of it in the live-action mcu
movies the whole way i mean he basically
ruined spider-man's chance to kill
thanos in infinity war because of his
own selfish
anger and and vengeance so you know he's
a spider-man had been the one to do it
in that case
they wouldn't let the kids be like kids
you have to do it
you want to be part of this group no
i've got a snack i don't think it's a
matter of letting i think spiderman
okay all right we're all having fun here
but this is serious for me uh
[Applause]
i couldn't even get that out tommy tommy
has a new setup and he truly just has
changed completely
this is all business tommy i'm in an
office now so i'm all business spectalt
and
business is a booming
[Laughter]
and that just means like
that just means i've clogged all three
toilets in the office
[Music]
i think in that situation when they were
i forget what the name of the planet
they were on was that was losing ground
titan titan when they were on time i
think uh i think spider-man just has the
had the power to kill him if they had
weakened thanos spider-man was the one
that possessed the strength to actually
kill a mad titan i don't necessarily
think they would make him do it but i
think that any of those plans were
interrupted by peter quill's complete
lack of regard for teamwork and decision
that only he was he was alone the person
that needed to do it out of some sort of
vengeance even though every character at
that point had a reason to want revenge
against them so but i think your
reasoning is correct and i think that's
why he would
not go with his dad's plans because he's
just like not even a selfish nature but
if the selfish nature is just his
emotions taking hold and taking control
his emotions of like this isn't good and
i'm gonna do something like completely
off-brand and i'm going to stop my dad's
plans so i think you're still right and
i think i'm more right
[Laughter]
i love that about it
but i'm more right
i'm more right we are basing this on the
peter quill we know right now over the
past however many years we've known him
about you know four or five years but
like celestials live a long time thanos
is an eternal they live a long period of
time one changes over a couple hundred
years and who knows uh of peter quill
never had a relationship with gamora i
guess in this case we're talking about
peter quill at the end of end game did
have friendship with these other people
did have the benefit of this but while
all of his other friends erode into
skeletons over the millennia don't you
think that celestial gene is with him
that entire time is it possible that
could corrupt his mindset i think that i
don't know because like it is peter
quilt because like if you remember at
the the first scene in guardians one
when he's talking to his mom his mom's
like hey you got into a fight with the
boys again and you got a black eye
because the boys were poking a frog with
a stick like you're just a good kid like
you just really like defending life and
so like or he wanted to put a
firecracker in the frog
i was like you didn't give me time
fine i'll do it myself he just hated the
wb frog so much he's like oh welcome to
the wb and this
[Laughter]
baby
boom i believe you guys are referring to
michigan j frog and uh batman
tommy i'm gonna jump through this screen
and choke you out if you continue
it's gonna be hard to do america's high
five after you've burned your hand with
a firecracker
but no like legit i feel like peter as a
person um is just a really good kid and
he likes to defend
life or things that are um are being
picked on which is i feel like why he
punched thanos after he like you know
after thanos killed gamora because he
was like yo like
obviously they were like romantically
involved but like he's just like it's
just who he is it's like yo you
are obviously bigger than gamora and you
just killed her you were her father and
she trusted you and you just killed her
and so like i feel like peter's just a
really good person and
you know i
i just feel like that goes oh you can
believe that empty but it's also just as
believable that he just views gamora as
his uh mommy
and
like in that moment he reached out to
her he uh briefly saw her as his mother
on her death bed reaching out to him and
that love has a total oedipus connection
to it like we can i you make your case
i'll make my case look i agree i think
peter quill is ultimately a good guy but
we gotta we gotta talk about this
because uwatu said this looks like it's
gonna be the end of the world now that
ego and quill are together now is he
saying that he just wouldn't have had
the guardians to like rescue him from
that moment of guardian's volume two or
that peter without these relationships
would have chosen to just forgive his
papa for giving meredith quill cancer
and said this is all i have now and who
even knows if he's gonna know that you
know what i mean like will ego be what i
mean ego could lie to him and there's
not a you know there's no fallback he's
gonna want a connection with somebody or
something so you know if your father
comes into your life out of nowhere when
you're 17 years old however old he's
supposed to be in the in the what if
episode like i'm sure that ego has a
long time to lie to him and like kind of
basically gaslight him into believing
whatever he says and maybe even
understanding
in quotes why he did what he did so i
don't know i i'm talking i think i think
peter quill is gonna be peter kale peter
but no i think a really good question to
ask here is you know what do we define
ego as a typical celestial because ego
could easily just be a celestial with
mental illness and like does mental
illness run strong in the family like
how strong is that in mental illness
gene if ego is mentally ill because we
but
what mental illness are we saying is he
like is narcissism a mental illness i
mean like i just feel like he's just
he's just like a sociopath like he just
uses women he impregna he impregnates
them and then she's like whatever
they're just my tools they're my pets
like omniman you know so it's just like
it's
i what if that
gene like what if peter could have a
mental illness i i don't know i'm just
spin ball i'm going rogue well
sociopathy isn't uh isn't uh hereditary
but psychopathy is psychopathy they
believe but i think he is more of a he's
just a narcissist than anything because
he go i don't know yeah i think he's
more of a narcissist than he is like a
psychopath i think he's just like i
gotta do this like this is for me like i
need to do this and so i don't think
that would be but going back to the
original statement sorry uh
peter kill i can't get over that
peter it's
not to say that
at the end of the session
i think that is still a disney franchise
and going forward it's like he's still
like the heart of everything and he's
still not the heart of everything but
he's still just a good boy
he's a good boy and he'll always fight
but i know what if is a reason to be
like what if he is the villain he could
be we don't know but i still think he's
still gonna realize i think he has the
capability to be either i think the
argument really is nature versus nurture
once again uh and i think in this case i
think peter quill's nature is good i
agree with everything that's been said i
just think it is possible with the wrong
influences in his life he could become a
villainous character well who was he
raised by again without um when his mom
do well no okay no stop okay wait no
like at the beginning of the movie is it
the first one he's it's his grandmother
his grandpa his grandpa so if his
grandpa's raising him until he's 17 when
he or whatever how old he is working at
the dq and what if that's old enough to
be at the age where it's like if he was
nurtured i still think he still have
that nurturing being inside of him it
wouldn't be like chaotic but that is
also assuming that his grandpa was a
nice person
yeah we don't know
we don't know that guy
this is true this is true we don't know
father's gonna be pretty terrible
yeah and who knows how much he could
have been kind of like a runaway and he
just checked into his grandpa at the end
of the day but really he'd spend all of
his time with some creepy teacher
oh my god oh yeah this sounds obvious
what are you talking about excuse me but
no i think this actually raises a really
good question with gamora because like
obviously like gabor is completely
different but like gamora the the gamora
that we have post end game hasn't met
the guardian so like she hasn't had that
family influence so like what type of
path is gamora going to be on because
she hasn't had the nexus event of
guardians one so like does she become
like you know like the the killer that
she is in the comics like this ruthless
like bounty hunter woman like i don't
know i think she's like a realtor on
[Laughter]
yeah look at all this real estate well
whatever she is i hope we get some
gamora of it oh my god you're fired
you're fired get out of that office i
don't unclog the toilet i'm so proud of
you
i'm gonna go make some delicious quaker
oats quicker
for 150 years they've been making oats
that you could be proud of tell me i'm
taking away
we're taking away the past robux that
you've gotten no please i'll be good
i'll be good i'll be good
i'll be good you'll have a chance to be
good to be good but uh but i'll give you
back uh two points for agreeing with my
pr uh with my proposal that peter quill
could be evil so you're back at zero uh
empty you're gonna get one point and
remind us how peter coyle saved frogs
and gotten fights over it that's
it uh and then jessica uh i give you one
point just for being a good sport you
know what that's fine
i'm fine with that i'll take it
you should give get rid of one of
tommy's because he clogged all the
toilets
i already
dinged them twice yeah i'll give yeah
mario you get one uh so we've got some
more theories about where the collector
got all those wonderful toys but first a
few words from the folks who help us
make rogue theory we've been getting a
ton of compliments about the latest
obsession shirt inspired by what if that
dropped over a new xstarsmerch.com it's
a cool artistic uatu silhouette and it
comes in three colors
the cosmic witness is what his name is
here these go fast they run out they're
limited edition gotta catch em all by
doing this you're showing your support
for new rock stars and you're getting
some great nerdy gear and you can do
this again at newrockstarsmerch.com now
we want to thank faridy for sponsoring
this episode there's still plenty of
summer left and no matter what your
plans for this season include faraday is
here to help they make the perfect
clothes for summer verity is a
family-run brand making high-quality
timeless clothing with a modern design
and functionality they've got the
perfect summer clothes that are
comfortable and stylish they fit great a
few members of the new rockstar staff
have really been digging the shirts from
parody why not me how come i'm not a
member of the new yorker who's who's
who's wearing the shirts
i'm still working from home my dog's
howling
i i don't wear any of the shirts but i
did stitch a bunch together and i wear
them as a cape
oh
i saw that the other day very nice very
majestic let's see oscar producer zach
thinks their plaid shirts make him look
more competent in the office our screen
producer wants to do some lounging in
one of their linen laguna shirts verity
is so confident in the quality of their
stuff they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality they'll replace or fix your
clothes forever no matter what and to
top it all off faraday is giving the
rogue theory audience twenty percent off
head to faradaybrand.com and use code
rogue checkout to snag 20 off all your
summer gear that's code rogue at ferrity
f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand.com for 20
off we also want to thank dect.com for
sponsoring this episode one of the true
joys of truck ownership is the amount of
stuff you can haul around with you at
any given time
it makes you want to go to home depot
and buy a bunch of stuff just because
you can problem comes in when all that
stuff you're hauling is rolling around
or out in the elements that's why
you gotta get the [ __ ] drawer system
for your truck
decked makes organizing accessing
protecting and securing everything you
need so much easier each of deck's true
full bed length drawers can carry up to
200 pounds of whatever you got the
drawers roll out waist high giving you
easy access for your stuff these drawers
are weatherproof protecting your stuff
from the elements because of the way the
system sits in your truck if your
tailgate is locked you can open the
drawers and all your stuff is secure the
deck's drawer system is 100 made in the
usa
and backed by a three-year no hassle
warranty with a second to none customer
service team ready to answer all your
questions get your decked drawer system
and quit letting your home depot haul
rattle around by going to
dect.com rogue where you'll get free
shipping that's dex.com rogue for free
shipping on your decked drawer system
decked dot com slash rogue and we also
want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this episode if you're carrying a credit
card balance month after month it can
feel like you're in a never-ending cycle
of debt like when lady seth kept kneeing
loki in the groin in a time loop upstart
can help you make that final payment so
you can get ahead upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you are more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan with a
five-minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
1 000 to 50 000
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com rogue that's upstart.com
rogue don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com rogues all right back to
episode 2 of what if
how did the collector get all of a [ __ ]
this episode is set in the year 2008 so
at this point the timeline captain
america shield should have been frozen
with him in the ice junior would
probably still be firmly in thor's hands
and presumably hella and korg should
still be alive one would hope did tyvon
kill all these people did someone worthy
hang mjolnir up in that rack for him or
is he worthy
how did he manage all this and uh could
these actually be maybe variant weapons
taken from alternate timelines or are
they from this timeline what do you guys
think what's the story behind these well
uh big big daddy thick fan himself says
that uh the collector
looking by the way looking good in that
shirt i wasn't that was that a
uh
it must have been faraday because that's
the only quality shirt i know that would
fit someone like that anyway
he said himself that the collector rose
to fill the vacuum that was left when
thanos vacated his spot now thanos you
know at the mcu in the movie versions we
know is a very like
he doesn't think of himself as the bad
guy he thinks he what he's doing is good
so
if the vacuum that he leaves is a
you know is occupied by a person who is
more malevolent or like you know someone
like the collector that just obsessively
wants to own things that yeah there'd be
a lot more murder because thanos wasn't
killing indiscriminately thanos was
killing with a script a script that
sounds a lot like genocide as is brought
up in the episode a lot but that doesn't
mean that the collector is gonna have
that same moral code he might see
something he covets and like you know
maybe uh
maybe he killed thor maybe he just took
mueller maybe he figured out a way to
coerce thor
maybe maybe it was some sort of deal in
which stella hello was also killed was
the same transaction maybe he killed
hella and that got him mjolnir i don't
know i just mean but we know that he has
he employs basically thanos gang of like
incredibly powerful
henchmen and henchwomen so it's like
yeah he could just be going around
killing and collecting uh you know
artifacts in the universe with way more
of a murderous uh drive than thanos ever
had thanos was just like thinking i'm
the good guy restoring balance or
whatever so yeah yeah it stands to
believe there's a lot more dead people
now because of the collector being in
power i like that theory a lot i mean i
was thinking about these all
independently what exhaustion what an
exhausting trip that must have been but
no you're right had he just taken one of
these things the rest probably would
have fallen like dominoes i
completely
and i hate to say this
agree with tommy
we're doing our best when we're
harmonizing sweetheart come on
but no i completely agree especially
when
especially when he was when he brought
up basically killing korg um i was like
oh yeah he definitely has just gone
through and killed everybody because he
does have now thanos is like henchmen so
it's like what's
all that he's missing which we don't
know but he's missing like the stones
he's not going for the stones he's just
pure like strength i guess but um i was
just like yeah he must have just done it
all after him like saying like yeah i
killed cork or well you didn't kill
corey he was like i took the arm off of
a really chatty chord basically uh when
he did that and then having all of those
weapons i was like yeah he must have
just like in this timeline uh captain
america must have gotten out of the snow
or the ice or he must have taken it from
him in the ice but no i agree with tommy
full-heartedly um i would love the idea
of him going through different timelines
and taking it but i don't think he has
the power to do so i think he's stuck in
his timeline he's just going to every
place collecting everything and stealing
everything those are really good
theories but i think that obviously i
think loki might play a role in this
because
if you think about it the collector
filled the vacuum for thanos and so loki
probably needed somewhere to go after
thor one like you know he's like hey i
got the cast out of the kingdom so like
he's probably gonna team up with the
collector and so he's gonna be like hey
man i know you like collecting so like
i'm gonna suck up to you and try to get
as much cool [ __ ] as possible so he's
gonna go down to earth he's gonna take
all the stuff and be like hey check this
out check all the stuff like i got my
brother's hammer that like i don't know
i stabbed him and like now here's his
hammer and like here's this cool shield
from earth's history and like all this
stuff and like i don't know maybe he it
maybe the collector helps him take over
asgard and like they have like a deal
going on because thanos and loki had a
deal so like i can see that loki
striking a deal with the collector and
that's how maybe the collector got those
daggers that he had like the dark elf
daggers and all that related stuff so
like i think there has to be some type
of deal with loki because as we see in
the loki show lucky tends to be a nexus
person like a very important part of
every universe so i wouldn't be
surprised if
some type of connection that's why i
think more reason for loki to be locked
up in one of his cages right now because
i was like it's also because he's he's
different he's so different he's special
and it's like i want you and then in
this episode he was like you have
nothing to give me t'challa like you are
nothing to me you don't have any
superpowers why would i keep you here
dissect him so i was like more reason
for him because it's like if he got away
with killing hella and he got away with
somehow getting the hammer from thor he
must be some sort of like very powerful
in this universe in this world i was
like i i just think he's gonna be
killing everyone i don't think he's
really working with anybody but that's
also me i was like he's giving off this
vibe more of a tyrant so it's just like
i don't think it's really trying to work
with anyone else yeah i think um one of
the most important things to look at is
that garage like he clearly wrecked his
own brother's uh palace on sakaar like
so if he could turn on his brother i
think we're just getting evidence of he
went on his own kind of conquering war
path well what what
we're assuming that he he conquered his
brother grandmaster stuff but what if
they're working together because they
are the elders of the universe and they
do work together in the comics and this
is the tavonne corporation so like i can
see like the grandmaster being like hey
man like what if like what if all that
stuff that collector has is from a grand
master tournament where all those people
fell like thor fell and like you know
maybe cap got unfrozen early and he fell
and like it would just be really cool to
have like all those trinkets from all
the dead people from a big like
tournament um like probably an even
bigger tournament if like a battle like
a battle planet
yeah like a big battle world yeah like a
battlefield like that it would be a
battle or battle
like battle
you got brad pitt in there yeah
work yeah i can't remember who else was
in that movie the i only
storyline in japan i think that's dude i
think that's also possible i just think
they're both too big narcissist is the
word of the day you guys two big
narcissists that i think would battle
out for like their own stuff because he
still was like this is my world and look
at my fighters and it's like well i want
one of your fighters weapons and it's
like no you're not getting one of my
fighters weapons because it's mine i
think they're boys they like toys boys
with toys boys like toys uh let's see
tommy i'm gonna give you a point because
i feel like you're a theory
uh nmt i'll give you a point because i
like your theory so our point scores are
jessica and tommy with one empty with
two but it's anyone's game as we head
into rogue questions okay so
our question this week is a reboot of
home alone will premiere on disney plus
in november and it will feature cameos
from mcauley culkin and uh devin rattray
that's uh kevin and buzz mcallister
making it canonical to the home alone
cinematic universe without me giving you
any more details about this i want you
to pitch me your modern updated reboot
of home alone exterior
rochester new york
december 23rd okay oh my god 22.
that's it the camera the camera slowly
moves inside the house
of a two-story
middle-class neighborhood
37 year old tommy beck told
uh with a bunch of presents waiting for
the arrival of his family who live in
rochester tommy showed up early on a
secret flight to surprise them
now
he has texted them all and they have not
responded and he's wondering why and it
doesn't even say delivered on it so it's
almost as if their phones have been
turned off smash cut to aruba tommy's
family has just arrived at a beautiful
island resort where they were planning
on going on a vacation and using their
green screen technology to trick him
into thinking they were in rochester
while he was in los angeles they didn't
know he was coming home it's a reverse
home alone it's the story of me being
abandoned by my family it starts me
uh it stars that uh cgi youtube star
from asia that got signed to caa uh it's
uh that's not a real person it's just an
ai uh it's it's also starring that uh
french instagram campaign against
alcoholism that just featured that girl
but they didn't tell everyone it was an
anti-alcoholism campaign but she was
drinking in every post and she went
viral as a as an influencer but she
wasn't a real person it's the three of
us
uh and the voice of police academy one
through five's michael winslow who's
having a moment right now he's doing all
of the sound effects in the room michael
winslow is in the room with me and
the movie is called
alone
oh
oh
tommy i love that pitch can we just give
tommy the win for that
no
that was a beautiful
i'd be like okay uh why are you giving
me exteriors and interiors okay
let me i forgot a couple things i have
robot legs in this okay
in the studio wars uh warner brothers
and sony are in a an actual physical war
in l.a and i lost my legs in the studio
wars doing a one-day co-star on a salmon
movie on the sony
that's the opposite of what we want we
want a robot penis with human legs
but sometimes the legs are all right you
know what i'm a guy who can take a note
so reverse it robot hog
human stance
okay give him my point he's gonna we
gotta cut all this out i can't i
okay my my home alone okay it's a
christmas miracle what is what is home
of america christmas uh baseball so we
have a mix of angels in the outfield
christmas angels and then we have home
alone and we call it home run and
[Music]
um the plot though is a little iffy um
because mccully culkin's character is
dead and is a ghost in the outfield
but he's not an angel he's just a ghost
in the outfield
that's what i was implying he is he's an
angel in the outfield oh he had it but
he had a bit of a bad habit on earth and
he didn't make it to heaven so now he's
a ghost
you were talking about field of dreams
because it doesn't feel the dream oh it
is dreams it is
no no i was thinking of the kevin
costner one angels in the outfield right
yeah yeah that's what i'm trying to do
christopher tony danza and joseph
gordon-levitt our angels in the outfield
and adrian brody and maggie hey that's
true everyone's in that movie
baseball movie with people dead in the
field and one of them is macaulay listen
the only home alone reboot i care about
is me and jessica telling our families
we're going to be home alone together
for christmas next year and they can all
kiss off
that's all i care about
like a big bear in a cabin a nice fire
i love this give tommy my point
all right i'll give tommy your point
and tommy gets empties point yes uh and
tommy gets another point from me
uh
and that brings tommy up to a total of
who knows but you're our winner
yes
[Laughter]
it was all that passion well welcome to
all of you i love that round all three
of your movies sound pretty damn good to
me
um but there can only be one winner and
that's tommy and that's it for this
episode of rogue theory i want to thank
our guests uh jessica clements tommy
beck told nmt you can support our
channel by checking out that new that
new loki themed merch at new
rockstarsmerch.com
is this copy old might be we're on a new
disney plus marvel show called what if
but we also have a new what if design
that you can check out at new rockstars
merch as well follow me at ea possible
let me rock star subscribe here on
youtube
and i'll see you next week off the rails
[Music]
you